じゃあよろしくお願いします
えーと 今日はあの頭に良いこと悪いことという
体に良いこと悪いことというテーマになりますが
はい では あの お話をさせていただきます
えーと あの あの 大量に風邪薬飲んでいるので
今日は話の内容はなんか麻薬中毒の人が言ってることのように支離滅裂になる可能性あります
で ですから 何か変なことを言ったら
まあそれはまあ私のせいじゃなくて
風邪薬のせいにするということにするしかないんです
まあどうしても避けたいというものは風邪薬ですけど
まあ避けられない時もあります
ですから 今日の朝はとにかくもう風邪薬を大量に飲んで
もうさっさと作りましたからね
まあスライドの中身もまあ信頼できない
まあ良いと悪いと決められるということって
今日のテーマはね 体に良いもの
頭に良いもの 悪いものということなんですけど
えーと まあどうやって良いか悪いか決めるのかっていうね
どんなものでもね ただあの
一つのものじゃなくて
世の中でね どんなものにしたっても
どうやって良いか悪いかって決められますかという問題ですよ
で まあこれぐらいのことはよく知っていると世間が思っている
大体みんなまあ良い悪いことっていうのはまあ知ってるんだそうと随分思ってるんですよ
まあ我々は生まれてくるから大きくなってる過程で
まあみんな平気で まあそれは悪いに決まってる
これは良いことに決まってるっていう風に
まあまあ言われて大きくなってきたんだから
まあ誰でもなんかもう思ってるんですね
平気で それぐらいは知ってるんだと
良いこと悪いことぐらいは
で 何が本当に良いか悪いかは断言的に決めることができるのでしょうかっていうね
それで我々のは絶対的に断言的にこれが悪い
これが良いと決める能力があるんですかね？決められますかね
世の中のすべてを 白黒に
区分することはできるのでしょうかと
できるできますかと これが白
これは黒と これは悪い
これはことしっかりと
あるいはすべて灰色ですかと
だから結局は自信を持ってこれが悪いと
これがいいとっていうのは言える状態では
我々状態ではありませんね
私だけならそんなのはできないと思いますけどね
優柔不断で生きる生きていられるのでしょうかと
それだったら結局は優柔不断になっちゃうんですね
悪いと良いかと判断できないということは優柔不断だから
では優柔不断で生きていられますかと
これまた困ったもんで
優柔不断で生きることはできないんですね
そういうことで よく考えるべき問題点は
そこを初めからもあるんですね
何が良いか悪いかと決められますかというと
これまた難しいし だが
すべて灰色かというと
まあそれはわからないし
まあ全部灰色にしてしまって
優柔不断であまり判断しないで生きていられるのかというと
優柔不断で生きていることも難しいんですよ
なぜか まあ判断するときはときは基準が必要ですよ
何か基準があって これに合わせて
あ これが悪い これがいいと
基準が必要なんです  工場で品物の品質管理するときと同じことなんですよ
いろんな工場でいろんな品物を作って店に出してますから
その場合はこの何でしたっけ？品質管理ということをやってますからね
その場合は基準があるんですね
これこれぐらい条件そろってるならば
まあいい品物で 店に出しても売り物になりますと
しかし こういう条件そろってないと悪い品物で店に出せないということで
例えば卵にしたってもね
大きさによって 重さによってもう変わるんだからね
なんか店に行って見たら
卵にしたってもＬとＳとＭがあるんだから
だからやっぱりそれも一つの基準で決めるんですよ
卵は円でどう決めますかと
円でどのように決めますかと
基準があるんだから もう判断できますね
だから判断するには基準が必要なんです
これで基準といったっても
これは 3つあります 一は
基本的にどのように生きるべきかと
基礎概念を作って それに合わせて生きる
まず 我々は生きている上で
人間ならこのように生きるべきですよと
こういう風に生きた方がよろしいかと
これぐらいのことを勉強して
これぐらいの体力はあって
まあなんとかなんとかとかね
まあこれぐらいの生き方があればいいと決めておいて
それを基準にして それに合わせて生きると 1番目
2番目 何かの目的 ゴールを決めてそれを目指す
目的に向かう生き方は良いもので
目的から遠ざかる生き方は悪いと
2番目は何か目的を作る
目的を作ってそれを目指して頑張っちゃうんですね
何か学校は合格するぞとかね
あるいはもう会社をもう作りますよとかね
もうなんとかなんとかね
で なんとか自分で目的作って
ゴールを作って その目的ゴールを目指して生きる場合は
ゴールにゴールを目指して生きる道が正しくて
ゴールに反対になる 邪魔になるものは正しくない
簡単に言えば 試験合格するぞとゴールを決めたら
試験を合格するためのことはね
勉強することやら 塾に行くことやら
宿題することは良いことで
もうゲームセンターで遊ぶことは悪いことになるんですね
だから目的があると良いと悪いと決めます
でないと何のことなくゲームセンターに行くなよ
ゲームで遊ぶなよと言ったっても
これが悪いんだよと言ったっても
何が悪いのわからなくなっちゃうんですね
例えば 子供たちが勉強するのを目的でやるならば
もう 1 日中ゲームセンターで遊ぶことは悪いことになるんです
だから 目的ゴールを決めたら
またその基準によって良い悪いということは判断できます
3番目はその場で適当に判断する
この基準もないし 基礎概念もないし
ただ適当にその場でその場であ
これが悪いんじゃないのということで判断しながら生きるということを
3つ基準があるんです
だから この基準があるならば
良いか悪いか判断できます
基準がなければ 良いものか悪いものかとわからないんですよ
例えば ゲームボーイでゲームやるのは良いことか悪いことか
そんなこと聞いたっても答えがないんです
何か基準に合わせてみないと
そのことでどんなものでも独立していい悪いと決めるのは難しい
麻薬にしたっても同じことで
麻薬が悪いですかと そう簡単には決められません
何かの基準に合わせないと
例えば麻薬という化学物質は
もうわざわざ研究して開発したものなんですよ
それもそれなりに何か基準があって
必要ということでね で
治療として使ったりもするしね
その場合は まあどうしても避けられない医者が
まあこういう麻薬系のものは治療として
薬として投与する それは悪いとは言えないんですよ
しかし 好き勝手に使ったりする場合は
我々頭悪くなっちゃって依存してしまって
人間としてもう大変な不幸になってしまいますから
それが悪いということになるんです
だから この基準があって良い悪いということを決めるんですよ
そういうわけで この独立した世の中のあるものは良いと悪いと決めることは不可能です
よく覚えた方がよろしいんです
毒キノコは悪いですかと
そんなわからないんですよね
それでまあ食べたくなったら悪いんであって
食べなかったら自然なもので
それなりに何か働きがあるでしょうに
それから毒キノコも人間にとっては役に立つように使うことも使えることもできるでしょうに
だからどんなものでも独立させて
これが良い これが悪いと決めることはできない
基準があって合わせて決めなくちゃいけない
そういう場合は 時々悪くなったり良いことになったりもする
同じもの ある基準では悪いもので
ある基準では良いものでという風にもなります
それからちょこっと説明していきます
1 基礎概念って何でしょうか？と
正しく生きるためにガイドラインになる基礎概念などは世間ではほとんどありません
だから これ皆様にちょっと理解が難しいと思います
世の中であまり基礎概念というのはないんです
いくら勉強したっても
まあ人間たるものはこのように生きるべきですよという基本的なものっていうのは誰も知らない
ないんです だから基礎概念って何なのかと
これわからないと思います
まあ一つわかることって
こういうこと 民族 文化
習慣などで人を基本的に管理されていますが
それも変わったり進歩したりする
例えばある民族 例えば皆様は日本人ですから
日本民族なんですね だから日本人だから
日本で生まれたんだから
まあこういう風に生きるべきですよということは
生まれる同時に決めてしまっちゃうんですね
それで子供の時から死ぬまで日本人として生きている
それで日本人に適用するいろいろ決まりやら習慣やらしきたりをちゃんと守る
挨拶はお辞儀をするとかね
食べる前に何でしたっけ
いただきますと言うとかね
食べてからごちそうさまと言うとかね
えー例えば食べて終わってごちそうさまでしたと言わなかったら
すごく行儀が悪いってことになっちゃうんですね
それでちゃんと挨拶をするとかね
いろいろありますね それで学校に行っても
よく挨拶できる人間になりなさいとか言って
いろいろそういうのを称えたりする心に
で それは日本人で生まれたんだから
日本民族の基準なんですよ
だからそれで基準って何やとわかると思いますよ
それで ヨーロッパ人にはヨーロッパ人の基準があって
アジア人にはアジア人の基準があったりして
それぞれ生き方 なんとなく決まっているということでね
それで善悪判断するんでしょうに
だから我々大体知ってる基準といえば
基礎概念といえば この民族的なものやら文化的なものやら
習慣的なものなんですね
それで見事に管理されてますよ
日本ではご飯食べましたと言った途端
もう箸が入ってくるし
西洋だったら食べようと思った途端
もうナイフやらフォークやら入ってくるし
アジアだったら何も入ってこないし
手で食べるのは当たり前ということで
そこでアジアではもう食べるところでいろいろ箸やらもういろんな道具そろってくると
何やこれって ちょっとおかしいんじゃないかなっていうことになったりするし
皆様はラーメン食べようところでフォークを持ってくると
なんかちょっとおかしいと
ラーメンはもう箸で食べるんだと
決してかけそばとかね
もう箸 フォークで食べるってこと考えたことないでしょ？食べられますよ
かけそばでもざるそばでも何でもいいんだけど
あれはなんのことなくフォークで食べられますけど
考えたこともないと思いますよ
まあフォークで食べるんだったらスパゲティぐらいですよと
スパゲッティもラーメンですけど
結局は スパゲッティ食べると何のことなくフォークを使ったりして
焼きそばを食べるとまだ箸を使ったりして
同じものなんですけど
ただ 焼きそばっていうのはスパゲッティのこちらのバージョンで
スパゲッティっていうのは
これは同じラーメンの西洋バージョンですよ
だからものは同じなんです
やっぱり文化的に そこでちょこっとした習慣が決めているんですね
それで良い悪いというものを判断できるようになったりする
情報が自由に流れる現代
決まった基準を守ることは難しくなっています
それで現代時代 これも困っちゃうんですよ
なぜならば かなり情報が流れていますね
例えば皆様 日本人だ日本人だと言っていても
他のヨーロッパの文化なんかはそのまま日本の社会に流れているでしょうに
だからまあ 結局その基準も入ったりするんです
例えば 日本人には日本人の文化がありまして
で なんで文化っていうのは
食べ方 服装やいろんなもんですよ
でも日本でもしネクタイでもつけなかったら
なんか人殺したぐらいの顔するんでしょうに
会社なんかに行ってみてください
ネクタイがして なんか裸で行ったみたいな感じで
すごい変な目で見られますよ
いくら才能があって能力があっても
ちゃんと背広を着ていないともう立場がない
あれって何やと 日本人だから別に背広ってのはヨーロッパの文化でしょうね
それで日本でじりじりと日本の文化がある
あの皇室のところ 天皇陛下に会う機会がある人々がどうやって行くんですかね
あの気持ち悪い あのて
あの なんて言いますか
え？なんでか あの あのコートのね
後ろ おしっこのように伸び伸びてるもの
わざわざとそれを作って
この人何やってるのかと
関係ないでしょ これは純粋な日本の文化でしょうに
あれが頭イかれてたイギリス人が考えたもんなんですよ
[笑い] わざとテールっていうんで
あれはね テールってのは尾っぽということなんですね
アホということなんですね
もうもともとなひんだからね
わざと作ってつけていくんですよ
偉い人に会う場合は まあ大体アホでない限りは
そういう偉い人にどうしても会いたくてたまらないという気持ちある人
みんなまあどうかなってますでしょうね
普通にればいいんだからね
別に会わなくたってもいいしね
まあとにかく日本でも
この間の小池さんのね
なんか一人の女性がね
なんか変な服装でいてね
大臣でね 待って 外務大臣に会って
その時はね これってもう明確に西洋文化なんですけど
だからあのスカートは長すぎて
手でも運んで持っていかなくちゃいけないんですね
で それで何かサインでもどうやってするのかとかね
まあまあ大変です とにかくそれはなんでそんなことを
そんな変なことまで起こるのかと
この文化の交流なんですよ
もう流れていてわからなくなって
これは誰の文化かとも
ただただもう真似するだけで
だから現代時代では 日本人のは純粋に日本人でいることは不可能でしょうし
アメリカ人にしたっても
純粋にアメリカ人でいることは不可能ですからね
向こうも結局アメリカ人がもう金があったら豆腐やら寿司やら食べてるんだからね
ステーキは食べない それはもう金がない人の食べ物なんです
納豆を食べている だからそういうことで
現代の情報っていうのはね
もう簡単に流れてるんだから
まあ一つの基礎概念に固めて自分をしっかりするっていうことはできなくなっているんです
というわけで 良いか悪いか判断するための第1
この基礎概念というのはなかなか大変なんですよ
なかなか決められなくなっているんです
それでこの次に言いたいことは
なかなか日本訳はできなかったんですけど
で まあこれも薬のかせくじらのせいにするかどうもわかりませんだけど
あの まあ英語ではピープルドゥーノットハブファームグラウンドスタンドオン
まあもうなんですか これ
日本訳しちゃうと 要は硬い地盤ってないってことですね
生きるためには もうどんな地盤
地盤でしたっけ？地盤でしたっけね
あまり我々には堂々と生きるために安定した硬い地盤がないんです
我々はそれに変化する
この揺れる地盤に生きているんです
2番目にかの目的 ゴールということをどういうことは考えてみましょう
一般的に見られるのはこの方法です
これはみんなわかってますよ
よくあります 何か目的決めましょうと
ゴールを決めましょうということはね
だから 1番はわからないんだけど
2番目はよくわかります
人は様々な目的を作って
それを生き甲斐にして生きているんです
みんないろいろ目的作っちゃいますよ
まあ時々ね あまりろくな目的ではない人でもね
まあ洋上の奉行でもなりましょうとかね
あるいはもう怪獣のついてるカードでも集まりましょうとかね
それなんとかして それで目的ですから
それで元気になっちゃうんですね
だから何でもいいんです
目的があったら生きやすいんです
それ生きがいになるんです
テレビで見たんですけど
このお箸の袋だけ集める人もいたんですよ
これまたもうもう 30万
20  30万とか ものすごいいろんなところに行って
箸の袋を集める 集めて
すごく綺麗に整理整頓して
一生懸命それいろいろエピソードもつけたりして
まあそれもその人の目的でね
おもちゃもいい年をしておもちゃ集める人もいるでしょうし
フィギュア集める人もいるでしょうしね
これ取り上げ取り上げちゃうと
何どう生きていけばいいかわからなくなっちゃうんですね
その人々は それでまあ学校を合格したいとか
いい仕事を見つかりたいとかね
いい収入を得るように何とかしたいとかね
まあいろんな目的を作って
それを目掛けて挑戦するのは
よく世の中でごく当たり前
普通なことなんだ で それに合わせて良いか悪いか判断するんですよ
だから結局人間の判断というのは
頭に良いか体に良いかっていう判断ではなくて
この目的に良いか悪いかなんですよ
例えば東大にでも入ってみるぞと思ったら
これは頭に良いものであるか悪いものであろうか
そんな構わず目的を目指して頑張っちゃうんです
これってよくあるでしょ
いろんな目的を作ったら
もう体が壊れようがもう気にしない
相撲さんと同じですね
とにかくもう相撲でできるだけもう横綱にならなかったら
大関まででも行こうかなと頑張って頑張って
で もう早くも体が壊れちゃうんでしょうね
もう使いすぎて それでお相撲をやめたところで
また元の体に戻るということはもう大変難しい
だから相撲で まあなんて言いますか
うん まあやってる間はね
もう体格はいいんだけどね
一体やめたら あの体はかなり白物になっちゃいますからね
これで元に戻れるか戻れないかって
これまたわからなくないです
もう結局健康状態っていうのはあまり良くなくなっちゃうんですね
だから一応体の状態がもう壊れようが
精神状態がどうなろうか
まあそんなのは構わないで
自分の目的があったらそれを目指すんですね
人間っていうのは その場合は良いと悪いの判断は目的で決めるんですね
しかし 人間同士で目的が衝突することもあるんですね
それで我々に問題あります
目的あってありがたいわけじゃないんですよ
目的っていうのはむちゃくちゃたくさんありますね
まず その個人が自分勝手に何か目的を作る
次の問題は この目的は衝突するんですね
例えば 母親が自分に目的があって
子供は子供の目的があっちゃうと
その目的が衝突すると
母親と子供が喧嘩するんです
だから目的あったっても
そう簡単にいくわけじゃないんですよ
子供が何か決めても 母親の目的が違うんだったら
そう簡単にはやらせてくれませんね
もう邪魔したい放題邪魔するんです
であの 目的っていうのは
目的の衝突っていうことを考えた方がいいんですよ
例えば家族のね 奥さんの目的
奥さんの目的と旦那様の目的が衝突しちゃうと
最悪状態が生まれてくるんですね
だから喧嘩になるだけではなくて
どちらでも自分の目的に達することをできなくなっちゃうんですね
そうすると生きがいがなくなっちゃうんですよ
すごい苦しいことになりますね
それがもう体に心にもいいわけじゃないんですね
ですから このポイントだけ
目的の衝突ということだけよく覚えておいてください
こういう言葉を覚えておいて
世の中を見てみると 結構頭が良くなると思います
世界的に見てもよく見られるのは目的の衝突なんですね
例えば今最近なっている牛肉の問題
それも明らかに目的の衝突なんですね
こちらにはこちらの考え方
目的がありまして 向こうには向こうの考え方
目的があります それは全然もう同じじゃないんですね
そういうことで衝突するんです
ぶつかったりするんです
これでお互い困っちゃうんですね
例えば牛乳輸入しないと決める日本の政府側も安全確保というわけじゃないんです
いろんな問題にもう出会ってしまったりする
向こう側にしてもね まあそれまた確保ということじゃないんですね
だから世の中にどんな
いろんなものを観察すると
いつでもよくあることは目的の衝突なんですね
それでどうなるかというと
自分の目的は軽々く気楽に達することはできない
もう向こう側から攻撃されますから
まあなかなかうまくいかないということになるんですね
結局は  例えば ある子供が音楽家になりたくなる
音楽家といっても音楽大学に入るのではなくて
ただなんか楽器を弾いて歌いたいだけということで
それでも将来大人になったらそうするぞと
それで一生懸命練習したりすると
親がそんな不安定な言い方は困りますからね
ちゃんと学校 大学に入って仕事を見つかりなさいと
そうなってくると お互い目的の衝突でぶつかったりするでしょうに
それでも子供がすごい頑固でストリートパフォーマンスというんですか
もうそこになってもあんまりいい気持ちじゃないんですね
どうかで親にぶつけてぶつけたんだから
なんかちょっと問題が心の中に残ったりする
で 母親は楽しいかというと
それでもないんです 逃げたんだからよかったんだとか
それでもないんですね
で 母親もそれなりにもうなんとかその世界でも一人にな一人になってもらえばありがたいんだけど
やっぱりこちらの方がいいんじゃないかなとかね
だからどちらでも結局はいい気持ちにはなりませんし
楽々にうまくいくわけじゃない
それっていうのはよく世間にあることで
目的の衝突という単純な単語で
私はそれを表現しています
一人の個人の中にもいくつかの目的が生出することもあるんですよ
もう他人との衝突はいいんだけど
一人の人の頭の中でもいっぱい
目的いっぱいではなくて
いくつかの目的が現れてきて
これもやりたい あれもやりたいと
あれもやりたいんだと
それそうなると頭の中でもうぶつけてますよ
もう戦争が起きてます
目的が衝突しちゃって
これまたすごい最悪な状態を作るんですよ
自分でもどうすればいいのかわからなくなっちゃって
だからこの目的作っちゃうと
一人の頭の中でもいくつかの目的が現れてきますと
もうそこで衝突する どうせ目的っていうのは一つしかなりたたないんですよ
結局は一つしかなりたたない
一つがあれば これを目指してちゃんと生きていられますけど
いくつかが出てくると問題ですね
ある人の目的は他人に対して迷惑になることもあるんですね
また 目的の問題っていうのは
自分が勝手に何か決めるんだけど
これは人にとってはえらい迷惑
そういう場合もあります
例えば ある国が自分の領土を広げたいと
こんな狭い国では困りますと
それはその人々にとってはいいかもしれませんだけど
領土を広げようということは他人の国を攻めることなんですね
そうすると 隣の国としてみればものすごい迷惑なんですね
それで戦争を期待するんですね
その場合は もう自分の目的は他人に迷惑
だから他人の迷惑になる目的を作っちゃうと
またうまくいかないんです
オートバイに乗って暴走族になってやるぞ
それってすごい面白いんだよと
これは確かに面白いんだけど
本人にとっては でも周りからしてみればかなり迷惑だから
そう簡単にはやらせませんね
だから目的については
そのようないくつかの問題が現れてきます
次に言いたいのは この自分に良い意味のは人間考えてるんじゃなくて
目的に達するか達しないかということで
良い悪いは判断するんだからね
これをちょっと考え直した方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
それで 3番目 現場で適当に考えればどうでしょうかっていうこと
良いことも悪いことも
その場で判断することは曖昧な生き方の原因にもなります
そうということは 結局曖昧ということなんですね
精神的に強く理性的な人間
人ならうまくいくが ほとんどの人はそれほど強くないんですよ
その場で判断するではないかと思っても
これっていうのはかなり理性がないと
精神的にすごい強い人間でないとできるものじゃないんですよ
でも 人間というのはほとんどそんなに精神的な強さがないんです
いきなり本番というのは人間にできません
練習してから本番に出ますよ
それでも緊張しちゃいますからね
1 年間も練習して練習して
なんとかあの 競技に出ますけど
本番になってくると緊張してしまうというのは普通の人間ですよ
だからその場で判断するぞということは
まあそう簡単ではありません
一貫した生き方 秩序を保った社会などはできなくなる
その場で判断する世界だったら
もう一貫した社会や社会の秩序とかね
それを保つことはできなくなります
全然管理できなくなりますからね
人間というのは 自分の都合だけ考えて判断する恐れもあります
あるいは何か判断する場合は
自分の都合だけ考えちゃうと
それってよくあり得るんですよ
その場で判断する人間の場合は
これとても大変なものなんです
で 内容的にはすごく難しいんですから
そこら辺で一応切ります
もう良いと悪いと判断する世界ってどんな世界かと仏教から見るとそうなるんです
基準の問題が出てくる